- C'est une pratique que
l'on croyait appartenir asasassé
- Recours judiciaires ont été
intentés par des femmes qui ont
subi des sorts semblables.
- Ce sont nos soeurs, nos mères.
- Les femmes disent que des
médecins ont pratiqué une
intervention sans tenir leur
consentement.
- Comment va obtenir que
ça ne ne se reproduit jamais?
- Ce sont les médecins qui
seront visés par cette
infraction. La loi devra
- Bien que le rapport s'adresse
principalement au gouvernement
fédéral, les sénatrices invitent
aussi les provinces et
les organismes professionnels
du milieu de la santé à prendre
les moyens nécessaires pour
que cesse une fois pour toutes
la pratique de la stérilisation
forcée au pays.
Ici Valérie Gamache,
Radio-Canada, Ottaw